zero depth Z row deaths we're gonna do
this without dying and if I die I am
going to kill myself on camera
all right where the [ __ ] do I go raise
banner banner not in the inventory
no one gave me a banner how you doing
buddy nice shield you [ __ ] idiot
daddy dude what are you gonna do you
smell like ass I don't know what the
[ __ ] I'm doing right now
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] it you're distracting
me god damn it
you're obsessed buddy buddy buddy buddy
buddy buddy buddy buddy buddy buddy
buddy buddy buddy buddy buddy
my favorite move maybe the banner is in
here ah I am Emma High Priestess of
lottery castle will not find them they
house
listen I just want the [ __ ] banner oh
my god Chong
hey you got me the better hey lady
you're not so bad let me go down on you
baby oh yeah that's it
zero depth notes never dies surely
there's a bonfire here somewhere
it's like the closest one is pretty
[ __ ] far away oh wait don't vote
Donald Trump oh god what the [ __ ] oh
whoa dude it's Donald Trump supporters
dammit
oh they're taking me for a ride
y'all want something nice decor it's not
Christmas though [ __ ] I'll sneak up on
him whoops
I am the best sneaker in the whole world
ah [ __ ]
nipple crusher get a new hat your Fedora
[ __ ] alright let's let's let's give you
these guys some poke balls catch dish Oh
what the [ __ ] these guys don't even
notice I'm just fart oh my god what the
[ __ ] are you oh my god you're so creepy
[ __ ] off
god damn I hate you what are you I like
your belly what diet are on you on still
there catch this idiot let's stab this
guy in the Ogun what the [ __ ] is that
oh boy I [ __ ] up sorry I just realized
I have a dentist's appointment and I
really gotta go ah ha ha ha oh god she's
running goddamn she's fast for a fat
lady and now we're gonna sit on your
face we are running really low and Isis
these ain't ya know Oh
about that I'm actually fine [ __ ] this
man I am [ __ ] scared all right
[ __ ] let's get a [ __ ] out of me
before set a [ __ ] cage what the [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] all the cages man [ __ ] that
caves [ __ ] that cage [ __ ] that cage I'm
gonna [ __ ] all the cages oh my [ __ ]
ate the cages I guess I can surprise
[ __ ] sample okay surprise mom
oh my god no no
ah [ __ ] what that zero death here we go
that was the worst fist I've ever seen
in my no not I want to shoot no steer
for me mom and that's how uh-oh oh god
oh god oh god
eat your own stupid zero deaths but I
mapped that bed up that bad up a bit
about Peppa bat Big Mac oh I'm dead I'm
dead I'm dead I'm dead I'm dead I'm dead
I'm dead I don't want a hug mom I don't
want a hug mom y'all know me still same
oh gee but I've heard locate attack
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] you fell for that old trick
bitch-ass mother [ __ ] [ __ ] don't
know me so same old surely we must go
down here what that [ __ ] is your problem
what's good oh oh get [ __ ] on
no Jeff turn it oh baby baby why can't
we go ah what the [ __ ] oh my god jaysus
Christ oh what the little - no no
alright come on fight me alright yeah do
your move
nice one ass oh [ __ ] he's strong
I don't do any [ __ ] damage push it
down push it down push it down ah
what's good oh I'm in a Motorhead
lavetta's jab laughs alternate oven No
shia labeouf made me do it top of the
morning to you laddies miss me ooh ooh
direction oh [ __ ] what the [ __ ] oh my
god stop this is definitely a boss damn
it I am NOT ready for this all right
well it's come to that moment guys it's
that time where you have to man up and
face the consequences
we fought hard and we fought good
I'm pretty sure I'm gonna die now
this is hey
is that a [ __ ] tree it is isn't it Oh
awesome like honestly I don't have time
for you guys [ __ ] shine look at my
[ __ ] damage yeah this will go well
yeah this will go great thanks mom
thanks mom come on
what a [ __ ] do I do it's the worst boss
fight of all time is there a way to go
home I want to go home now
nice oh my god
no no
nothing last Silda never sorry I can't
be
how do I pop the pimples ya mean there's
a ball okay
damn it there it is
look we did some damage look at that
[ __ ]
yeah I pop your pimples all day son
spread your legs for me baby you look
good you look real [ __ ] nice what
just happened
what the [ __ ] hey could you not oh god
oh god
holy [ __ ]
you nearly killed me you're disgusting
he's a trash I hate you
damn you're sexy listen I can't run much
longer where's the penis artists think I
couldn't find you you're trash
is this what it's like giving birth to
children because if so I never want to
get pregnant she [ __ ] herself again
it's like an actual pregnancy
[ __ ] yeah no that was worth half half my
health
yes I did the trick
come on come on
no oh we're gonna actually do this what
the [ __ ] come on babies spread your legs
for me baby stab it ah it's not dead
it's that zero gosh that was the most
erotic experience of my life alright
thank you for us so much for watching
this video if you enjoyed please deliver
like I really appreciate it
I'm having a blast playing this game
it's so much fun and I really hope you
bros enjoy being part of the experience
and as always I love your breasts
seriously stay house ok cut it back up
now oh boy oh boy
hey catch this oh my god what's up God
cast that